hey hey hey hey Brendon what's up bro
long time no see man what bro that's how
we're doing it today like you're ready
to go and you don't want to do that you
you you suck him off every day that's
not you don't want to do with Brendon
that's not sure don't say that what yeah
I'll take you out what happened what
just happened in the bathroom I'm 6 feet
tall I've been telling them forever your
Heights in your legs and you got a very
short torso you're built like a frog
you're Billa humans I've had so much
conversation and critic criticism why
would you quit a second war what are you
we can't even give a guest of water
listen what is your problem already
oh you already got like you're mad
because what's up brother because why do
you man are we recording are we are we
live well I'm sad and I feel like you're
upset cuz steel took the guest of the
year and then I never met this
[ __ ] I don't know anything about
the old woman that [ __ ] belt that
he's walking around he got that [ __ ] on
line you're right he ain't the guest of
the [ __ ] year Theo von and you're
[ __ ] goofy haircut
it's a mullet mullet yeah why don't you
get a real haircut like everybody else
we'll see how [ __ ] funny what he'll
Street now cuz he's talked to me he is
he's taught to me talking a lot of [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy he doesn't know what's
going here's an idea you have a stone
wash gene hat on well it's gray remember
that stone wash I know I know but you
have a shirt for your body yes and it's
it's a mani pack but you know that ain't
[ __ ] Oh what what I can't tell what
the no what did you draw that an
ex-fighter yours I work for a Showtime
and now Showtime boxing your I can't
tell what the [ __ ] that is
hold on do you know what that is Brian
yeah who drew that knows what it is
daddy who's that is that okay
no that is right doesn't know they do
I'll take it semester strong
[Music]
I'm not gonna say who it is I guarantee
I can't tell
that's Roberto Duran it looks like Manny
Pacquiao every boxer has that picture
anyway scare back to this clean him or
I'm stressful before I get to your stone
wash Jean hat please do
Theo Vaughn alley cat later talking a
lot of [ __ ] a ton of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
with your [ __ ] mullet and your your
your your belt that you order online
that belt weighs about 1.1 pounds that
ain't got no weight
now it's real gold it ain't real gold
you don't gotta throw yourself as the
guest of the year and and and you know
what I always come around this time
where we're in late October
yeah well season you let everybody do
their thing and now you come in and I
know you know what I do I take that big
dick out and I lay it on the table no
doubt respect to what a tame cat cat
that big white bread maker I put it
right on the tier I come what's the
Asian dudes name Asian yeah chin no
you're the comic Bobby Lee he was sorry
[ __ ] he's he's a guest early like Nick
Kroll is a beast Nick Swardson please
Nick Kroll ressource
I do this is not a competition it is how
about this I said oh my god Morgan I go
this I go there I go I went to the
dermatologist and the term oh said oh
you're fine everything's good my
psoriasis like pretty much cleared up no
no no precancerous skin [ __ ] yes he goes
as Laos again who's your guy who's you
guys look at this [ __ ] burn this
thing on me I got a major major [ __ ] I
think I got well you're like I got skin
stuff so bad you'll be all beat around
the bush I got skin stuff so bad that
people misconstrue didn't think thought
it was something else
and he herpes and stuff damn bro you
know you're a step above an albino
that's what I got I got I got skin stuff
so bad at people you know they right now
we can't talk about our boys but are you
a vampire like you can't go outside
right oh I see now why I sleep with no
block but you brought you played a lot
of ball
outside I mean you're on the bench but
you played you were out there what I
don't brain what you saw Matt run
well it's not me run to me you quietly
impressed my smile and we go grab a
coffee while we talk in beer
I wanted to bring you a we go suck the
boys off what we talking today
hey wrap em bieed let's get it dude I
couldn't I couldn't be more excited for
the season what are you what are you are
you you jazz person for real no I was
just in Utah the Jazz are [ __ ] jazz
or dull Jonathan Mitchell's great
Leigh's dick you got good teams him
you're in the West it's I think the
sleepers are them and Nuggets and
Alice's but then but the Nuggets their
backcourt and then the Joker
yup that perfect triple double there
they're good I mean Steph Curry last
night was blatantly disrespectful rude
[ __ ] on everybody he plays for the
Warriors Brian no no I know
why don't you go get me a [ __ ] almond
milk lot yeah yeah you man good for
enough a meal - you guys are making me a
beta male right now I'm into sports
I know Stephan Pires Steph Curry went
off gold state off see that it's it's
almost unfair how good they're and
people say they've ruined the NBA
because of bonuses listen check this out
you're a car guy let's say there's a
rolls-royce and it's on sale for a
quarter of the price of the rollers and
you're you're a Honda Accord guy but
you're like I could get this rolls-royce
Elliott for the amount of my Honda
Accord I'm getting the the rolls-royce I
don't care that it's yellow and I get it
just for a year but if he balls out is
he in America and I still only paid for
a Honda Accord price they're getting one
of the best players in late for Hondo
court price don't blame the Warriors
blame the rest of the league who didn't
sign him agree but and they could have
signed them like Lakers get a bunch
people can sign him Golden State took
the chance but also if Thompson leaves
cuz he didn't he believed me but let's
say he does if boogie coz isn't healthy
it doesn't matter you even if Kevin
Durant leans they'd be fine if boogie
Cousins doesn't thing I don't think any
of them believing my prediction players
no bogies a hell of an ass Steph Curry's
winning movies and haffley Steph Curry
probably one yeah
shut your [ __ ] or theirs are gonna be
fine Bottomly and suck inside off no or
they don't listen almond you guys
[ __ ] omelet you [ __ ] don't go
Chinese Bell it's super disrespectful
man I'm not a shiner hey don't shine
bell Greek freak can win it MVP he could
win the MVP but I think he could win
nasty it's there there's a lot of people
there's a lot of pepper I feel like it's
the best time for them being a long time
how many superstars how many good team I
agree it's feel like it's the nineties I
thought that it was just gonna be you
and me and he'll tell you I was like oh
you're here today yeah I was just hey
wait a minute no I don't either when you
show that was I think your phone up and
text somebody no good [ __ ] sport oh
man that's not quiet as a dermatologist
I have a point of view on [ __ ]
basketball and I know you're falling I
disagree with what you guys are saying
and and also it is you guys are forget
him of herself and it's also cool
because um hey man that's my wall about
uh I think LeBron has his work cut out
for him he's got his work two years two
years of struggle City and then to me
that big was struggle I mean it's gonna
be finished six or seventh in the West
III I think once the playoff come he
takes over it cannot take over cuz cuz
there's other dudes are like [ __ ] you
but that team with Kuzma a Josh Hart I
think they're if ball can just eat kids
off
LeBron need someone to dish it out today
you're kind of dressed up like levar
ball today like how old do you man yeah
man now all they're know you know what
when I stepped out on my purple Porsche
today I thought [ __ ] you Brendan yep you
bro let's see who you have on right now
Stone wash like I didn't you're getting
too gassed up on your E channel dude let
me let me tell you some haven't worked
in a hot minute
I'll gated though okay but check this
out check this out oil careful I work
for Bravo Bravo
I know that you're those your boys and
I'm gonna tell you some right now
don't make me don't make me make antico
go bad on your name tag we're good we're
good
we know we're good - okay we're good -
and then I shave one tax what one one
taxing one tax and why yeah you know it
is a lot of people have a lot of people
probably want to have want to bed him
down
at Bravo but from what I've seen I would
know buddy he's all that bet him down at
Bravo and Ian oh he's like the fighter
and he's got like it's like I'm a
fighter I haven't fought ten years yet I
still have this [ __ ] deform to you
because I want everyone to know that I'm
a fighter like you like I don't want to
get your fix like because I want people
that don't think I'm tough I'm not
talking I do my brain that [ __ ] thing
hey we're in Hollywood you spent all
that time if you spent as much time as
you did on that E or as you did on these
goofy [ __ ] outfits that would be
better off
fix your [ __ ] knee hey man who'd you
dress like a stepdad in Highland you
dress like a step he earned that here
what change in and what's your name
Kat Kat if you look at every city on the
show you'll see that I've brought this
year but you my friend you're not a
supporter daddy's right I agree no I
mean it that's not style that's like
ironic yeah that's like ironic like I've
got a Utah Georgian I don't like you two
I just work now I like Utah okay but
they're not my team he's got more pants
he's got the cargo pants with those
laces you guys you guys are walking
[ __ ] Crocs you know don't touch me
don't touch me it's arrived oh yeah
that's my [ __ ] personage come on wrap
Brendan let me let me have a condition
when it knock you down a peg because
we'll say Oh like maybe like oh yeah
he's a handsome guy of my man what's
happening
look at your outfit my man look at this
[ __ ] Larry Bird a brand New Heavies
concert you're not in your not what's
the Donnie Wahlberg's band yeah you're
not even on the block
no you're not look at you I wish I were
your dress I got a story
Rosalie Ortiz he's 4830 I don't know but
you're around there you're a [ __ ] hair
away from 40 take that stole what you're
not a new addition he's not I wish I was
but you're nervous I would have it or
not
and you need to stop with this change
hey you know what you should say one
more thing I'm f chin walk this door I'm
gonna [ __ ] both of you no no I'm gonna
taste it normally the bone grafts branch
stupid [ __ ] teeth and Oh Jay come on
13 weeks is gonna hold you down and film
it Noorie go worldstar put it on there
worldstar I make my way over it's this
way but I'm gonna go we're gonna go
counterclockwise now head down you blue
not open it thank you it's it's he's
just resisting resisting and you might
wear Amaya that you're second you don't
know it's first first of all he goes
like this he goes no you better not
and he's like you burden I'll be so mad
and then he said oh this feels terrible
yeah yep and then you're just you're
throwing your three-inch nub in there
with with yours no you have enough
no your little pencil dick don't call it
that don't say that dude your little
pencil dude don't say it because I will
[ __ ] huh don't man don't play music
you gotta be cool to rap bro here's the
show on Netflix Brian's trying to show
what do we get what do we get a typical
just got picked up for what a start
she's no oh we're home why do i plug
myself was no I just I just wait wait
wait wait yes you're not a trauma Chris
Paul I like I go low you go three no
usually I thought you meant three out of
five stars and then I do CRO god Duke we
got season three what when you guys have
like somebody you're not familiar with
chin and what is it Kat god no when you
have like your gas stick come on like oh
you have your Netflix press or oh where
are you playing you're playing Cleveland
feel Vaughn you're gonna go to Cleveland
again that's a tough crowd come on did
you plug them but here I come here a
typical season three I am rap sport a
stereo podcast and and I have to plug my
[ __ ] self and I have to sit here look
and talk to a guy was pushing 40 with
that outfit on it's true
you'd look terrible you look like you're
in a boyband we know that from the 90s
but I really like this I agree with you
I think it's gotten worse
but pro-british I have more money more
problems okay man you know you're making
me angry stop talking about more money
no you do know you do don't act like you
don't know all I'm saying is you better
watch me [ __ ] tongue around rap
because he runs netflix bro he's on this
third season yeah what you trying to do
what you special on Netflix go do rapped
I get my special watch Oh we'd say with
the your comedy special yeah he goes
through rap with that same bit you've
been doing for this ever back my legs
are like circus animals that's not my
bit I don't say circus animals I don't
have the word so damn I don't have the
word
I have a short femur bone that's been
there's a joke I'm sad about your thighs
like oh they're like circus and what do
you say I don't remember what I said
about them because I'm so improve on
propositional and I have so many
different I want to say this I want to
say this and I've thought this before
and and I come and I break balls hard
yeah hard yeah I totally don't
understand why you don't have a Netflix
special Thank You about and especially
the reason why because one of the things
and I'll talk comedy right now and uh I
made my my return to stand-up comedy a
couple of weeks ago you know I know that
yeah
improv Wow that oh in Hollywood yeah
brother it was great I'm doing it again
actually Monday at Comedy Store
um but all new material um but you one
of the things about your stand-up that I
like and the Netflix specials that are
interesting is because before specials
whether it was HBO this place in that
place
they'd have each comedian would sort of
have their different pace now because of
our attention spans are broken in the
many minutes better be fired and it's
like everything has to be like an
Instagram post but yours is now you have
that high energy [ __ ] I totally think
Bryan Callen should have a Netflix
special I don't know why you don't are
you the reason he's not on getting them
to watch it is difficult so getting who
to watch Netflix like the people that
make the decision but I heard that
somebody who makes a lot of decisions
watched it and liked it so hopefully
that's the case we'll see what happens
I I don't see that as an issue have you
have you watched many comedy specials
lately I watch him yeah Adam Sandler
just dropped his I didn't see yet
it's different because you know he does
plays songs he's always gonna be funny
it's creative his [ __ ] it's definitely
unique he Kiko's all on his tour and he
cuts it all up from all these did you
write the yellow heart certified it's
not your typical if you're expecting to
sit there and see like a normal comedy
specials not that well that I think
that's good though because like I was
saying I feel like now they're all like
they're gonna it's like it has to be a
tsunami of laughs whereas before you
could sort of take your time walk around
the stage you know now it's like go do a
30-minute specials you know Netflix you
recorded one I'm going to record one
January for Showtime for how long is the
special hour Wow yeah are you like this
[ __ ] big-eared [ __ ] he's got his
special I mean I've been [ __ ]
plugging away what I'm gonna do for
[ __ ] for [ __ ] peanuts they're 30
years and you don't say 30 years but
what I mean like 30 years like I would
still talk about the circus animals my
thighs and he's got a special but don't
don't characterize me that way as a
comic number one but but because I'm
very very talented but here's what I'm
gonna do with him when he's doing a
special heckle is afterwards well
afterwards something's gonna go wrong
but be afterwards I'm gonna go I'm gonna
stand outside and his people God I'm
gonna go they go great he was great
right now
it took me a long time to write that but
I did a good job because he me my buddy
Jimmy Burke in New York used to do that
to me I would do a show
no one knows Jimmy Burke is I know it's
your friend but it's like the people at
home like they're like no one cares
about you they do they know respected
Jimmy no no no they don't he's the
Prince of New York and they all know and
they're all going yeah Jimmy tell us
mother story no Jay you know I don't
know who the [ __ ] Jimmy burns I know
another guy named Jimmy Burke and it's
not even you he would have a group of
women as goes my friend yeah but he'd
have a group of young actresses around
him and they'd be asking questions about
how he wrote the special and I would
come along this is this is a bit this is
why this is why when I come here I can't
treat this like a normal show I have to
sort a serious show dude how was the joy
Diaz I know she's always good he's the
best right yeah the first time I've had
him on a second time he's always good
and his special comes out I think Friday
know next week Wow Coco this [ __ ] guy
I mean you come
I can't keep over them a [ __ ]
specials get you a 30th I said next
what's it what's it on what never the
place you're the only mother [ __ ]
comic who can't get his special on him
and Christina Thomson girls wife they
did drop and Brad Williams and big
Junior Day ball oh no they're all on all
together why are all on thanks yeah all
of them have an hour
buh-buh-bah all of them having 30
minutes oh they did a special 30 minutes
I'm trying do you when you did your your
special did you wear that [ __ ] hat
why in what's happening January I'm not
gonna tell you again
I'm gonna rip off your [ __ ] listen
bro when you when you when you do it are
you gonna wear that [ __ ] hat pry
don't wear hats no not doing no but you
just wearing it today I have a sweet-ass
outfit on you're not gonna be like
purple and tight huh no maybe yeah you
met she's gonna be three pieced not
aware suits over to your boy it's in
February in January you're shooting it's
not coming out you're shooting in
ingenuity that's three months away yeah
be honest tell us just right here like
when you're laying on the pillow how
often do you think about what you're
wearing to the special oh my god oh my
god now three months away I bet you is
dieting already oh yeah dieting
definitely lost 12 pounds the other
thing is I've eight more to go I'll have
a few outfits picked out already already
you have a you have a strong girl Jean
in you and that's that's fine it's
coarse ain't a girl Jean is
disrespectful to girls here that is so
disrespects us your [ __ ] dog Lexus you
guys I'm just a little older that's all
complement my stand up more no I like
your stand up I totally think you
deserve a special call I don't think it
should be a problem call the people I
mean it's you they don't like maybe like
yo he's funny but it's ending it's just
him it is Brian you sucked up no no I'm
a good girl I know no you you betta mail
no no I'm doing a beta male so they're
like guys I can talk sports the [ __ ] man
Carlos Boozer I said next time on a
plane great guy Jesus Christ I thought
like me and you were gonna be here
because I didn't know he was gonna be
hit yes when I guest-hosted now
might have been but at one point when I
guess those in biggest at the time
biggest ratings I mean you know you're a
one-off it's fine but listen let me ask
you this
people were like yo I know for me say it
a lot they're like yo rapid job like
they could phone I know this is like
beat that [ __ ] horse down like yeah
yeah Jimmy Burke in New York beating
Yankees but when Britt rapper job it's
like you know it's like a hey watch your
shoes bro like I got circus animals in
my drives
take your shoes off my [ __ ] expensive
oak table Oh get filled in your FaceTime
FaceTime Theo von FaceTime no because
it'll it'll face down the nation took a
lot of [ __ ] on it why I bet I bet I can
FaceTime um let's see you next door
FaceTime alright knock door first time
alright let me see you dude give me
FaceTime me three dude man you're
aggressive yeah you are dude FaceTime
him they talk a lot of [ __ ] on the
internet FaceTime ah yes in here with
his fake belt got that as [ __ ] at the
Sport Chalet little init let him pop and
see this face see he's got to say see
what he says bring him around dude we
again go get us an omelet hey no I want
to be part of this no clot I'm serious
guys who he taken for if you have to gun
to your head you have to pick finals
don't state Golden State I'll teach you
so everyone's like Houston Canadian cold
state and felt a Boston go and say I
don't think Kauai and Toronto they're
not gonna do it
Philly's a little too young still Joel
embiid I love Joyland beat as a player
but you know what he flopped the other
day I he was playing Detroit Andre
Drummond who's like a [ __ ] true blue
goon I don't like the biggest guy on the
court flopping and falling I don't want
the biggest guy on the court being like
a funny guy who also flops that's like
one F is enough you could be funny
but you can't flop you can't be seven
foot three and like be a Twitter guy and
then slam good Jesus
but like eat what hi hey get the [ __ ]
out no soon there bit guy seven three I
can't dude but it was like a blink in
your eye
nobody he's having bribery full game man
well that's a second team Africa where
is it we're in Africa is he from what is
he from Nigeria
well this is right what is he from
you're gonna get the whole show shot
says Team Africa there nobody it's like
there's agonizing the [ __ ] mask over
his last name is Africa he's got bowling
balls for shoulders huh what you you
love that right no I'm just saying don't
know I'm noticing that he's he's a Jimmy
Lee Jimmy Burke no you're the guy be the
agent comedian Justin Bobby Lee Bobby no
bad with you day two name's Brad I don't
know these [ __ ] people bro you're
untrue they're like oh yeah Oh Bobby Lee
didn't V theof oh no don't be at the
improv big deal [ __ ] now when
I'm there yeah dude I'm gonna [ __ ]
heckle you bad huh call know what you're
gonna see come up there to see the old
veteran long like this is your doing I
go like this you just hear this laugh
obvious on the nose and I'll be like
workshop at first dude general you
general generally funny is that is that
a skin a bit no does that mean is I just
stand out I stand up like term no I just
come up with [ __ ] on the fly I was
talking to him I'm a star you didn't say
Brendan you text me because normally
when you invite me the show it's yo-yo
it will Greek text and I do say I was
like what did I say to you when you said
we're yep send location this would have
been a whole different put your fingers
I didn't know you gonna be here don't
put your fingers I didn't know Brian was
coming no come on man you did don't know
turn I mean I mean your phone give me
your phone give me your phone I don't I
want to FaceTime this mother I know
that's what I'm gonna do why are you so
calm pretension I'm not gonna date I
don't like people saying they're the
guests the I invented guest of the year
on this show I know I kind of did yeah
kind of did but now how many episodes of
your show did you get picked up for is
it ten episodes we did 10 last year we
got to doing 10 again okay what's the
name the show my [ __ ] wife it's
calling typical my Wi-Fi is not working
dude so we can't FaceTime on a Bobbie
Lee you can you get him to that so
you're no no it's [ __ ] cuz he's Asia
you get this guy on the thing I just
tried dude my wife eyes down just stay
with us here man can you just be in the
show
I'm just here you know what ringing and
there was no competition guess here I'll
sit here now go ahead dude show
everything's a competition with you do
I want to know what you do in your free
time we're not we're not into basketball
and talking loud
what would he got your question what
else you say you got a typical you got
your pocket just call what a tip my
stereo hot podcast with the rap yeah
no plug me man plug me it's Kiama
Rapaport stereo podcast right which you
guys have I am real just a bit on there
well lose this you're not there take the
stereo on Kimbo passed away i went on
there remember yes yeah you've never
asked me on that's amazing my draw
tonight can I do you a favor I quit not
a fit my drop my wait wait you guys you
guys talk is it all sports no they life
rap politic rap let me let him down easy
you're not a fit not a fit okay he's not
hey not the demo you guys are ganging up
on me right now man Kaneda came and if
we were to go to my mama go they're
leaving me out Jersey yeah I'm from New
York's the streets of New York
no Jersey dude no worries where do you
where do I get my edge from where
Connecticut Jersey where my dad was a
banker yeah they lived in Greenwich but
the point is this I spent a lot of time
and dad how good of a wrestler were you
I mean I went to American University to
wrestle which was a d1 so can you use
there any footage of that Minh and I and
then what happens it'll happen when you
get to American you know decided I don't
want to lose that kind of weight that
never I gone to take a base camp never
happen I mean you never run the American
no vision one wrestling no but I I went
there to wrestle scholarship director I
went to college to do certain things
you're like it's like everybody has a
dream that doesn't mean they're all
gonna become accomplished you want a
[ __ ] participation trophy that you
went there's no doubt I would have
[ __ ] made the team no there is yes
there is a doubt but you know about a
meter no you never got recruited ever
you would American numerously thought it
was maybe a good idea to join the
wrestling tsk matter how much weight you
might have because I just didn't want to
do it anymore
I think I was just like done and decided
to do what I back hurt I hurt my arm my
back I got a Dan Campbell's wrestling
camp and I was like if this is d1 ride
school yeah I went to I went to his and
then actually but so yeah you got
American University for you yeah yeah
but uh but but but but did you going
this is what I always go to college pro
so the guy the guy who started that
you're saying this means nothing but the
guy that I was this is the story I tell
the guy that started in my life we've
heard this story before
no this is a story my Netflix audition
got it
the only reason I don't know why I never
know starting I'd beaten [ __ ] your uncle
Rico you don't have an uncle Rico but
wrestling on that level is that guy I
don't believe American was even close to
what like Oklahoma right in that program
but it was when I went to Iowa I get
this is watch practice is d1 so you
trusted dang Gables sneakers are you
wearing rain dismay for me there I'm a
p.m. all around athletes they're not
even somebody like you got wrestling
right now okay it's a short story your
vertical yeah let me just say grab point
is if you have to if you have to add
anyone on LeBrons Lakers who would you
add no I don't know who I would add but
they need to get rid of somebody they
have one too many players who does the
same thing they have a two-minute
ball and then you got wrong all I like
and Rondo together yeah you get a pick
one something some things now rise off
something's not right like they need
like a they need like a JJ Redick a guy
LeBron can throw it out there they don't
have any time they're based on ball to
hit that's that's he listen he's been
making shots like a player every game
and this is an MBA and NBA player every
game he shoots an air ball I know you go
to the YMCA there's certain dudes that
never their balls you can miss shots
yeah but when you're nothing here Paul
it's very strange how he airball airball
it's his form I don't know airball
that's mental
but he needs LeBron needs own who he can
drive dish out there yeah I've dish
they're gonna be good though they're
gonna 36 or so yeah I feel good about
them as a team as he has a guy who can
dissed you today you know what's up dude
you need to do he need to Disher and I
said that from day one if the guy
doesn't have a dish
now he's got to do all the work himself
and we don't want him driving in the
middle because if he drives to the
middle they're gonna double up on him
they're gonna triple up on him now it's
gonna leave the flank open inflate Mike
which is which is another technique if
I'm coaching a team I'm [ __ ] I'm
driving the middle we need to keep that
wrinkle well I'm open flanks because now
what I got is I got I got marginal
shooters but they're flings overs the
flank is open so now you dish to the
left so what I say to LeBron as I go you
drive to the middle they're gonna double
they're gonna triple team what now you
got your flank you can shut you can you
can dish you can dish to the left or the
right
Oh cuz you got your left and right so so
it's a basketball is opening your flanks
oh wait right see you drive it you want
it you want to call off Phil Jackson we
call it the clog the middle open the
flanks so you want to clog the middle
you'll come out of fines offense that's
exactly what happens
think why do you think why do you think
SC always hits sorry Stefan curry cuz
they're clogging the mail on the outside
boom no no let me ask you a question dad
UFC 230 I'm sure you're exhausted with
229 and could be yeah McGregor enough
yeah please thank you rep I'm not for
ready we're friends yeah thank you um
I'll be in New York
MSG my house Michael Rapaport aka New
York you perform there at the garden
2:30 been there a lot I'll be at the
phone look at the fight I'm gonna be get
the [ __ ] fight ok ok whatever
no I've got good seats my guy Derek the
Beast Derrick Lewis yes
can he beat Cormier yes I don't because
why
just cuz he hit so hard but he would
have to eat it out I shouldn't say it
has to be in the first round because
it's five rounds in even though he looks
exhausted he still hits he's the hardest
hitter in that very division he has that
Shane Carwin power when when you're
fighting when you're somebody like that
who's clearly not a wrestler and Cormier
is clearly that's his strength right
he's got these times do you think do you
think Cormier will try to stand up with
him hey shut up everything when it comes
to fighting this I know if I know that K
about waiting for me a pizza [ __ ] you
it's not me and Bryan and now
me Brennan Kat and Jim Jim Fox it's the
fans hater all shut that I know the UFC
so you mind your P's life I brought it
up for him you because it's it's a
conversation here now it's I think their
clue I mean I think DC's like a - [ __ ]
900 what's the odds it's it's to say
he's gonna win it no [ __ ] yes that's the
e that's the you don't have general
general but wait but why though like I
know that I see yeah but I mean what is
just wear him out and he's fought big
powerful guys before and beat the [ __ ]
out of him on the ground or up top both
can he stand up there with that yes he's
way quicker cuz he jabbing it sounds
good defense you'll get to Indian
clothes what he did Frank Mir and all
those guys he gets one I was different
fighting fragmented fingers a southpaw
who's a black belt on the ground but the
thing and he put his head in his chest
and we're awful yeah Derek no no he'll
trip hood trip he'll try it he'll strike
a little bit with Derrick Lewis cuz
Derrick glows just loads up on the right
which don't you take advantage and Derek
cuz I I told Derek and if he does this
I'll take full credit but I was like
listen good good you got it you got a
jab this [ __ ] we like he's got
it works just not Derek style I know but
get me did you see on Twitter showing
goes dude please get better cardio you
just respond back no right like it's
just not his thing that's why everyone
loves Amami that's not tired gets tired
no I said cardio like you want bananas
in your smoothie aside please but with
with DC his whole thing's gonna be just
kind of yeah yes beyond it's like even
if there's a little bit of a gap Dr
Derrick Lewis can just land it's over so
used to be on like I what I think
happens is if Derrick Lewis doesn't lie
in something big
DC's gay end up very similarly Anthony
Johnson wrestling him down
wears him out DC are their clothes gonna
turn over on his back to stand up and
DC's gonna choke about DC is also really
hard to hit like he on Jones beg to
differ
yeah okay so the only person that ever
beaten the most impressive fighter in my
opinion to ever step in the Octagon is
Daniel Cormier you know I mean DC
doesn't it never was a problem with
going but he doesn't bring his feet and
he gets he's lost twice yes he's lost
when he's way sure
way short rate cardio should be though
here's the other problem though
DC's going to this fight with up with a
hurt hand his right hand spot how do you
know that DC's said it right I'm not
sayin jerd injured and he goes if this
was anybody else I would not be fighting
my I should be waiting till next year if
it's anybody else I meaning deep the
dear closest is such a good matchup for
him yeah you can just take him down try
and try why I want peace - I like DC I
was [ __ ] Derek Lucic if I want to
make money I put a grand on Derrick
Lewis as a dog it's not a terrible bet
just because he can knock out any point
and let's say DC does let's say he does
try throw his right hand and breaks it
let's say worse way worse nice fighting
with one hand [ __ ] man it's hard to grab
it's hard to grapple it's hard to get a
hold of guys then you're forced to stand
with Derrick Lewis you don't want to do
that no kanata kid we're gonna take
three of yours just to land one of his
right so I don't mind betting on that I
don't think there glose is gonna win i
think DC inventory's gonna probably
second or third round gets his back joke
to me I think he's gonna get him either
against the fence and they beat him up
and then take him to the ground and kid
okay if DC wants to put dirt loose on
his back every time he'll do that I
don't care how about it even if he's
coming any I mean he comes in like he's
I just wanted to win so bad he's so low
he knows a lot of people do and he's
just so smart he's a great guy
his story is fascinating too because he
was done you know he's retired and I
told my said dude I think retire Diaz I
was I don't want to say more because I
don't I don't really like doing it like
I don't enjoy this [ __ ] anymore he goes
in my back was bothering me was my kids
and then I was retired for a few weeks
and then UFC called me threw me in
offers I can't don't retire her is this
much money to fight he's like [ __ ] it
let's do it you know I fight for a title
and it was on short note in the garbage
we already noticed you fight in DC who's
you know so I would say go you know
there's there's a high argument for that
he's the goat so you find him short
notice
I literally think it's the only time
Derek Louis probably could have got a
title shot I like it man do it I loved
it DC's literally one my favorite
writers all-time fight human beings of
all time but I love [ __ ] I like the
story if you were to win and be great
ten
and the last thing about 229 cuz I don't
want to get in the whole thing is that
[ __ ] I mean the night was so nuts
that his knock out with 11 seconds left
was so rocky for that he got
overshadowed by his his speech it like
his conversation with in the ring out
and then stuff after that and all the
other [ __ ] to which were we're not
getting into me do people forget that I
mean I don't say people forget but he
was getting his ass
what yeah for that yeah Volkov is that
monster yeah I was getting his it like
that was not a very good fight no no I
mean it was he was it was over that and
that's why it's so dangerous egos you if
he picked him down if he can't get a
finish early on like in the more you let
dirt clothes hang around if that right
hand lands on anyone you in trouble
can he throw the left who do beasts at
size thing thing and his ground and
pound let's say for some recourse his
crown could reverse DC just drinks he's
so strong if you can reverse them his
ground pound it's not now question no
just just a like a timing like you know
a science thing everything took basic if
if DC wanted to [ __ ] I've sparked him
excuse me beat his ass sparked him and
have his way with him and you had to bet
all the money you have cuz you've
mentioned I'm I got this I got a purple
Ferrari yeah well I would know it's got
a purple on don't be out worried what is
it correct us a warship three are you
have to bet you're purple to come in
your suburban Corvette yeah it's not a
Corvette bro it is it's okay you say I
have to bet my purple Porsche how quick
DC uh the Beast could [ __ ] the bit of
him oh dear close to it to him
hold on and you have to be within 15
seconds you say a minutes all the hot
air 15 seconds in this confined to this
low lose me in here how long
no it would all be fun no for Peter ring
put me in a ring
I've sparred DC you're gonna do what are
you gonna do
we're what are you gonna do where are
you going yeah what are you gonna do
what's my head yeah my head never stops
moving bro I'm not kidding my head never
stops moving so it's just it's that but
what's this huh bring my hands up look
at my head
20 minutes of his one hour I haven't
gotten one being talking for 30 minutes
chin yes I have questions not a water
this water come on I got to see my diet
coats are not good for you but I wish I
had something hold on vending machine
out there cat you want my card here take
my card you got it you know forty what
do you want I'll take a diet cola two
diet cokes what do you want I got you
again
[ __ ] smoothie let me get a coconut
please taiko going on with two straws
and two shaved ice and ass thank you
listen man get yourself something you
think if do you think if it'll piss do
you think if I do different subject now
you think of DC goes to heavyweight and
fights John Jones it's a different fight
I got to see what John Jones looks like
when he fights guess in the end of
December I got it because John Jones you
remember I think he's the best fighter
ever graced the Octagon and I don't
think he's the guy who's done steroids
you know he took a lie-detector test and
he said he didn't know what he's talking
take you know like you I didn't know
that yeah so all his stuffs coming out
now he's not as terrible as we thought
and cheater and stuff like that however
last time he was on a strictly side of
testing and he had a long way off you
remember and he fought OSP looked like
he looked human hmm Oh speed went off
five rounds on so if he does that a
heavyweight with DC you see it a
heavyweight is your primary it's super
right Derek and and um their final
regular have you ever done 65 okay yeah
now so John Jasmine I got see how John
looks the ends just show just so we know
that's that's the fight though that's
the fight and then you get John
Wednesday Gustafson is he monster but I
saw that fight but he stays he washed
you my feeling with Gusman is he said so
many wards that's what I'm saying and I
don't know but I could sometimes a
question is hard I would say talent wise
it's I mean did he I'm talking about
like this light heavyweight it's John
Jones
DC Gusman even everybody he looks so
good against a clever tester and
whatever Clippers last fight he looked
great Gustaf's yeah here's something
that's intriguing what it's like when I
saw the gus-gus Jon Jones fight I
thought [ __ ] that's a tough fight for
Jones come back to Goss hasn't fought
even pretences since John did he he
a longer leg I know I injuries mmm yeah
that was a Trudeau fight dude his fights
with DC he was like he was Wow a minute
away from beating John giant no people
thought he beat John yeah he was a round
away from being DC so he was this close
I just think it takes it out of him I
made 2017 the last time he thought wow
now I predicted on the nose I'm newer
just gonna say this and just let you
know cuz you know nothing and you're
supposed to know I predicted fourth
round choked out khabib on the nose let
me ask something and it's on record some
rap what yeah the only time ever been
like truly mad at you as a friend you
everything you do I celebrate everything
you do
I didn't celebrate season three very
typical well we don't care cuz I've seen
the first two seasons yeah it's one of
my brother's favorite show I loved you I
anyways he's never seen it she didn't do
you think may have Netflix account no
you don't know what was right on that
sure big deal
hey the only time I've ever been like oh
it's for reals mad at you is when live
at the car McGregor fight we lost 40
Mayweather and you're talking all that
[ __ ] to me court of cage saw her rings
yeah I was like this [ __ ] dude and
but you might guide though we're boys I
was just I was just I was annoyed at the
rest the fans and when I got to you is
like bringing me into the fighter before
after the fight whoa both cage side
night and Connors walking out of the
ring oh yeah dude I'm proud you you were
you were you were like wrapped shut the
[ __ ] I please Raab give me a second man
I was drab give me my face what did you
think was gonna happen
yeah but forget about that we're doing
what were you mad about no not the only
thing is is as soon as Connor loses your
avatars Corrigan punch in the face I've
been doing it occur but but but I'll
just I'm on record
people either love rap or hate them I
wanted with the Conor [ __ ] from from day
one yeah so I'm all yeah we're never you
were never a Connor Peppers listen no I
was never a kind of dick writer I don't
believe in great white hopes you believe
in great white ups watch Rudy you
believe in great waiters offsides
watch watch Rocky I don't believe in
that like I believe in great white
reality Larry Bird gray road we were
great reality yeah
Gregor's quit but the fans Ryan County
yeah exactly comment I but I don't
believe it Greg white helps I'm big
leaving great white Mike so the thing is
is like I know he's dope I know he's
great and all that [ __ ] with amo fighter
all that [ __ ] not hard but when when we
fought Nate the first time that's when I
was like cuz I [ __ ] with Nate after I
told I [ __ ] with Nate hard but the dish
because you [ __ ] with Nate doesn't mean
you can't [ __ ] with common I just didn't
respect him yeah I know but but you have
to hate on Connor because but his poor
yellow Brandon I know but you gotta
realize him fighting Nate is something
you have to respect out of Connor don't
worry much bigger of course short notice
fine but but a terrible master what's
your what's your least favorite football
player in the league right now Brady I
don't know what's your team uh you hate
I don't hate I'd seen my promise I'm
hating teams I'm not that guy though you
know he'll I don't like they got the
Cincinnati Bengal uh you the guy you
don't know linebacker Bronte's perfect
he's an [ __ ] okay but but you don't
have a team like growing up and in my
song bye dude what's up okay but I don't
hate any fine of course in the saying is
that's why the thing is differ because
you you're part of that community but
with sports
it is it is the only safe haven where if
you're doing it in a respectful way I'm
not into fighting fans I don't go to the
stands and [ __ ] you but the beauty of
sports is the love and the hate I know
but your avatars Konig and punch to the
face why he said he was gonna do all
sorts of things any windup good punch in
the face
oh man and he not only get punchy face
he got what Li right hand Levi's hand
blop yeah how you throw a punch but
nobody was it wasn't like it was nasty
that was the end of a fine you don't
bring don't but again you gotta have
respect for Conor a guy who takes all
that time often fights the world that
should match up on you
that's on you to take the time if that's
on you to throw the [ __ ] thing for
the baby but he changed the game you
mean one hundred million dollars doing
this Andy you might have spent it all
know he talks a lot so what you're
saying if you're gonna talk and you get
banner back you know like do you like
Tyson Fury I like him yeah he's gonna
get his ass kicked by but you think yeah
[ __ ] yeah I don't know hell yeah Deonte
on your pot yeah he's great guys yeah
well have you have wild on no you
wouldn't love him I'm sure so do you not
to why was my boy fury yeah sure he's a
character I give a hug
dude you're [ __ ] but let you but take
all that [ __ ] out of the way and be
honest and it's hard because you know
both of them now whose win that fight
I mean I feel bad you're cold I feel
like the better boxers will fit bro yeah
don't save we're bad again okay
Wow if I want to make money if I'm a
better man I want to make money on the
fight I'd pick the gypsy king to win in
12 rounds yeah by decision II - yeah if
he out points him doesn't hit most
experts say hello he gets yeah he gets
caught in the eighth or ninth round
deonda has gotten caught but he got
caught against a very skilled who is
right he's he's a southpaw real year old
Cuban man skill that was a yo he's a
model yes
49 no we have no idea how old 40 but me
and Tyson Fury thinks he's 49 but he's a
skilled [ __ ] dude look out scary yeah
the thing is about him no one wants to
find no say but no authorities Ortiz the
Cuban southpaw
undefeated and skilled well a boxer and
and this is a thing your owner is owed
Dante's chin dude he got [ __ ] blasted
by Ortiz he and and Tyson Fury's not
gonna eat not I just think the I think
there's only been put down really once
against Cunningham it's here and I think
it was in the state he's a boxer I mean
right Furies are hot his foot waxing
wise he's he's on a higher level than
Dante right as far as like as far as the
motions and he's got all the tools
better footwork and all the better
footwork not not a not a knockout blow
no no but better tools Isis I mean they
say that down to other hits harder than
anybody in the division wonder-percent
wasn't he wasn't what do you know three
none allegedly wasn't a Tyson freer on
that booger sugar yeah I said I might I
just released based on the time I have
here play it so I run three on my
Instagram watch this he talked about how
he was a fixture Mike how he was 400
pounds wrap he's 400 pounds and all he's
doing is drinking beer and [ __ ] doing
cocaine
booger sugar booger sugar okay devil's
dandruff ha ha ha ha there it is I like
I'll play the other one too though wild
are already you know it's got a little
bit of a layoff
turn off years two and a half years on
the beer two half years I wasn't like
two half years of just you know living
it was turned off here's a party live
yeah
it is funny we're plugging your pod but
now I'm just saying yeah because they
were so far behind me when I stopped I
need yeah look I think it's been done
people have done better jobs our
comebacks in this sugar I learned it at
five year are not eat one come back five
year before yeah you ain't Marvin you
eat Sugar Ray Duke I was just done Tony
Montana I'm beer can we can we show a
clip from my show sure man yeah Don
that's a noble play the other one play
the other one what he says about this
because know what I want to know why
we're surely played for me he's playing
on guys play the first it's not about
you it's not about you be quiet nobody
cares about you what I'm saying gonna be
wise they became my told
I'll beat Wilder and if I'm no good
dinner lose simple bout Klitschko said I
cannot be cleaned up I must be [ __ ]
meself
what's it [ __ ] go can box he's useless
I told him no I told Klitschko to his
face I said you're useless you've got
three punches a jobber right under the
left dog and hold on to me if I can't be
among the three punches and I can't be
anybody now while there is only got two
punches left ducking right and so if I
can't be a mum or two punches and I must
be rubbish how many lenses do you have I
have every punch in the book he only has
to he has the big left dog woman big
right up boom they're dead though and
his feet I like I don't know he's like
an ice skater when you fake like this
chasing me across the ring with two big
white legs and a big mouth fake if it's
a battleships
looking at me I just I just can't see
how he can beat me wait Joshua it gets
even better
really I've got him spine anthe Joshua
is this stage boy this is it staples the
fight to stay positive some brief uh no
December something out of town December
1st um I'm at that [ __ ] go do it
yeah I'm at Demmel you don't have to
show my thing I got enough followers
hook up there Showtime or you went you
prey on my tickets I'm in New York
performing psycho so I got you you can
probably imagine I gave your tickets
yeah
ringside yeah you said it say it again
to the camera rap can have my tickets
Brian day look wrap up whoa 1.4 million
followers I didn't know you were that
popular I am Brian grass but you don't
call me when the show premieres no
listen oh my god that but what else do
you do are you still doing the three on
three basketball thing man there's a
four point shot yeah I remember that
season yeah big big thing you're mr.
sports yeah come on bro anything with
four point shot no I'm happy for you
though
are you I promised him though the rumor
was his Kobe was gonna do it and then
Kobe literally shot that no he didn't no
he did not to come home he didn't say
that Adam how Obie's not playing Kobe
Kobe would never disrespect the big
three and anybody to disrespect the big
three is this disrespectful cuz number
one you're disrespecting you disrespect
an ice cube which how could anyone don't
I do love cube all three Fridays what
maybe what Friday was rapping he's like
what what's Friday now thriving who come
on good that should be in your Netflix
special hey don't be disrespectful
that's a good one for your Netflix
special yeah but see all series he's in
Friday after night there is right there
play that for that's next Friday Mungo
Craig it's actually next Friday next one
that's I said why say Friday afternoon
yeah come on I got a delivery it's kind
of hot out here buddy come on come on
Sparky nice house they expect you to
answer but this is a place yeah what are
you one of those uh entertainer guys huh
see how relaxed damn is enacted Brian
Brian's like I wish I could be right I'd
I would do it differently but I like the
choice hey don't want any trouble with
you you'll have to send your Posse out
here to do a 187 in my ass just cuz you
say in my ass not on it yeah in my
partner partner see that well the
greatest annealing I love it ring
attacks notice I hope the cracker
killers pay well back to the ghetto you
go either you do inflection in the
ghetto it's like 60 seconds it's just
masterful holy six to me only six eight
thousand why is he even help with that
it's okay that's one of the greatest I'm
a dude I love that funny but how cool is
cube to work with he's [ __ ] that's I
mean math oh yeah you've worked with him
on ride-alongs he's a mastermind they're
great guy he's a smart [ __ ] dude
smart and just a good dude and a humble
dude and you know he's a feet
then he left the Beatles and went solo
NWA was the Beatles of hip-hop and he
wrote most in the beautiful
[ __ ] the Polish people what do you see
mastermind behind NWA then we got the
[ __ ] out he wrote went against them yeah
so I mean he's [ __ ] dope and he's a
good dude and I don't know why he why do
know why he would never come on this
[ __ ] podcast and if he ever does
shell call to him right now I can't I'll
[ __ ] make sure that he knows they did
the teasing you've made about the big
three and I'm not tease I'm sad I don't
like the four point shot why not you
can't make it we've been through this
rap who's the white guy behind them are
you Moses have you played ball hey when
you swallow a seal do you think you'd
beat me in a one-on-one I would get rap
no I think you think you'd be me a
one-on-one basketball thing rap aren t
it no you don't play basketball well
dude how do you shoot let me see oh you
should have just let me see you like
that's right let me shoot me yeah I hit
13 nobody on your form
all right he's got a stand up what okay
let's let's see yours I like this let me
see I could already tell you can't shoot
like I don't need to shoot on you I'll
Drive in the you'll score a point I'm
gonna by default get this right here and
you're bored we're playing piston rules
we go father went for playing holy [ __ ]
we put money on this [ __ ] Bieber
I will dunk on you put my nuts and
Duncan yeah I can okay dunk [ __ ] on from
pushing 40 both you figure 40 years old
how the [ __ ] you gonna dunk w6 one are
you sick - no either ask your [ __ ]
life no no listen mean he said he said
he's a much better athlete than you
stronger and much fans oh [ __ ] but
dialysis but I get your technique when
it comes yeah I think you'll you'll
you'll be able to shock him and you'll
be able to you'll be able to hit the
problem is he'll get in your kitchen cuz
you're you're a historic yeah y'all
gonna make nobody know what I mean is
your hysterics and so you'll go you'll
start to freak out and you'll panic
so then you're so happy you have a
typical body I am Rappaport stereo
pocket worldwide phenomenon yeah baby
typical just got picked up for season
three and then what and then three on
three basketball
I mean I mean what the [ __ ] else do I I
mean how much can I do that's Lobster in
any movie
either there's something I might do I
don't know yeah movies aren't the same
they're not it's crazy movies aren't the
same like you have to really consider
what what and why you're doing a movie
for me I have to consider it doesn't
move the needle in other words well
unless it's the unless you're the main
guy or it's you know DC this or
marvelous because well depending on well
no no what I mean is it like you said it
depends on your role cuz you can do a
lot of movies and you'll be in Bulgaria
for nine month and it means you know you
get there like you're basically losing
money to be there I said you know I shot
my first movie rap when I was texting
you and got no response
never dad never have service won't be I
did a little movie called tax-collector
with David Ayer you never texted me that
did you try looking did not I did you
did not wrap any any guy will hold you
down you're right I'm like good would
you play I played a cartel member Latin
yeah let me hear your Latin accent go
ahead no I'll get being the right guy
did you have tattoos
no well you couldn't tell I was dressed
like a real Mexican cartel so it's
covered up covered up now like tattoo
right here no let me hear you lie tax
and go and we know one speed and action
hey Holmes cut cut cut it was really
good get another [ __ ] actor in here
now cut can we give him one more chance
okay
he's a spider rolling speed and action
hey okay I know he's nervous
cut the n-double-a-cp is gonna be all
that's a stereo to give him the other
this is not cheese much I know can I
give him the other line just calm down
the other line no I don't want to do I
don't raise a good day to die just say
that nope I'm not give that a shot all
right
he had no help from me rap huh you gave
me no hello I never not have your back
yeah he's Shia LaBeouf play Latin no he
plays a way to base off true story a
white boy who collected for the cartels
in Los Angeles right heard about this
Jesus Christ what is it coming out next
year
have you seen anything this year so far
like recently you Brian
have I don't go to the movies yeah I
just see I see movies my kid you know
I'm saying cartoons like a little foot
or other Fight Club I saw that great
mind doing with my son how old's your
son seven I just watch him watch it
that's my ice to go to sleep yeah I
straight up I used to like bring a
folded up sweatshirt fine what movies um
oh I'm at home watching Netflix and [ __ ]
like make a murderer - is it good make
party though it's a little slow it's
good it's just basically like ah [ __ ]
Steven Avery was definitely innocent I
can watch the younger one
Brett Brendan Dassey 100% yeah he
shouldn't have been in the frisian jail
so Brendan I'm not sure I don't want to
google it but they appealed it the court
said he should be getting out and then
they appealed that so he's in that
process you know it's a dope podcast
that you've you listen to the Aaron
Hernandez podcast yes I just finished
part three this morning
yo he is [ __ ] what homeboy catch
football psych you did hombre catch
football psych you dick he was it was he
gay or bisexual yeah he had a [ __ ] up
life dude his dad was basically super
abusive his mom drug addict uh flying's
it's super tough but the crazy thing
from why I got from the podcast is it
there was no trouble until he was in
college yeah which is like rappers when
they get they start getting jail records
after their platinum record after that
money in the bank that attracted hard
with him he ought to cause start acting
crazy survivor guilt or someone they
said he was too young cuz seven senator
Mayer got him into college when he was
17 which they do freshmen that didn't
happen at Capo's the school years for me
they they try to get maybe watching it
they wanted me to wrestle at American at
16 you know my problem with that podcast
within an Hernandez is it's like just
release all them at once let me get to
it on my own you know wait if I know I
know I know
stupid I wish I didn't know Benjamin all
the way through like they just released
harmony Arden there's at least three
that where he's at Florida yes today
yeah we're talking about they talk about
Tim Tebow in the AAA yeah like Urban
Meyer [ __ ] Tim Tebow damn bro I mean
years ago we're vibing here man
you're friends with him I was gonna ask
you if you sucked off Ice Cube for your
roles and [ __ ] but I didn't go there did
I normal quiet
Tim and he spent a lot of time I know
cuz why do you like well Tim's my good
friend and I'm like you ever sucked him
off no he's so good-looking that I have
you seen ty had a girlfriend drinks
here's a real girlfriend like to say it
like dimepiece girl if I had a couple of
drinks
it would be hard as a straight man I'd
be like ha I shouldn't do this you know
with Tim Tebow I'd be like Mike secure
my hips are you a hater on him too I
never had a problem she who's your
football team
Giants Jesus Christ did you get low on
that - the Browns right now do you know
what I say when I want to be cool with
guys who watch oh yeah what do you say
they ask me what my favorite team is
well I'm from New York so they sass me
your answer Jets what's your favorite
team bro I know Giants are Jets bro it's
a complicated question man and then they
all get it they go yeah I got you yeah
your Giants but you've got a circle of
game it sounds like no one no real
circle bro just sounds like I'm [ __ ]
giant are so bad then they traded away
snacks deidara throwing in the towel
what about O'Brien go get us a chick
back um Julia we would like I mean it's
a detriment to your your podcast that
this is oh I know sports
I know Giants I so this is what I need
to cuz I actually had to fill up my tank
of gas I need gas I need that [ __ ]
Valley one or and I need like lunch dude
I'll get you lunch I get to lunch we can
come [ __ ] BMW that's on your
B's is this 7 Series it's gonna be me no
it's an SUV what is it 5-1 i-5 I don't
know it's a mom would you get it's a mom
cone I tested my tech my test says don't
worry about it do you like that car I
never have anything but a test why
although Porsche coming out the electric
car I like electric cars but but but but
are you scared that the guy who created
now that he's like [ __ ] out of the
company like you're not gonna be able to
get that thing we're just not the
president it still involved
the bigger question was their debt their
debt structure was the question was are
they gonna get bought up are they gonna
go away and that's insane it's gonna be
like I mean the reliability the
reliability record is not good they
finish like 16 is that right yeah it
finish like I thought it was the exact
opposite
I don't follow yeah of course meanwhile
I I've had no problems there's some
electronics the reason why the
reliability [ __ ] goes wrong is it goes
in the electronics it's never like the
actual car I don't want a car that's
like an iphone that linear itching or I
don't want a car that's a car engine I'm
gonna have to adapt it you know but
right now I [ __ ] hate but it's got
such a just look so gay in it you want
[ __ ] I mean he ran to get that little
Parker that he's wearing and some get
out of it don't call it a little it's a
hard it's a medium yeah but don't so
don't say seem little can you it's a
medium that you took and got altered so
it's like it's like do you have a wide
back so mediums are always tricky for me
because I got a I got a wide that I got
a deal Vaughn bring them in who the [ __ ]
is that
oh [ __ ] bro oh [ __ ]
and you know this producers with them
Vaughn himself flat ass so Sophie oh I
I've never met you you got a lot of
hairspray in your hair that gymnasium
that's natural gas Teddy okay no you
know where'd you get that [ __ ] belt
feel this right here yeah this isn't
that that [ __ ] like online like how
much is that [ __ ] away I don't want to
touch it well look if Brandon showers
right there one spinning so much money
on his goddamn socks maybe I'd have
something nice maybe I'll take this real
gold I was on two percent almost real
gold that's gold 24-karat you know that
belt is fake but that's fake news fake
belt no this is a you tickle that nickel
baby this is real stuff right here man
and I'm out there doing the Lord's work
I'm robbing Peter to pay Paul Zynga's
baby all day you know that poor see yes
all day baby I'm uncomfortable he's a
southern Robin Hood listen listen the
bottom line is the people in the bottom
fancy not voltage fans you'll steal baby
okay so let's do a test right now whose
do the guest of the year like ask
questions do assess maybe do it all okay
Sam as an impersonal owner ever the fans
did say that Theo von no fan said it's
you out
voted baby no they didn't yeah you're be
white and blue to full baby you know
right Mike you're being a little bit of
a sore loser right now generate okay
because it was a little sorry it was
Theo Julia well he's on crystal Lee
winning [ __ ] he was never been the
conversation now we see eye to eye on
something I invented guest of the year
I think I'm 16 did he win it 2016 2004
on it and then you came in here and you
made a belt up for yourself my friend do
you have a strap daddy he's asking you
regular to claim this thing's heavy man
this thing probably weighs about nine
pounds I got that from Vince McMahon oh
this is the or son so yeah baby welcome
is Happy Days maybe I'm the Fonz with
the bronze daddy you feel me [ __ ] you're
moving like Stevie Wonder I've got
butter this is real butter and some of
its getting in my eyes baby let me ask
you a question
I would like to do a test right now
throws like an old blockbuster yeah I
used to go to spit booths when I was
younger I know a German piss bars are
but what's the spit food you know
chicken but I've never played anything
like that
spit boom now in New York City what's
this pitbull Brian come on use your
[ __ ] brain
it was the peep booths on 42nd and
you're going to watch movies and guys
with jerk-offs booze all you went to
spit booth
he smells like lube and hairspray that's
America smell like baby that's Aqua Net
he smells like a blockbuster in Aurora
Colorado Oh baby that's diesel gasoline
breath wash my legs with DS now do a
quick test like guys like a thing here
like guests here and that will let the
fans go dude
fans did it do you know boating work
Sports Chalet that's Halloween well this
I did get it on sale the fans voted and
he knows it he knows it and by the way
we and we're doing stem cells donations
for Brian this week this strap will be
continuing to tour America I'm just
stopping it by right here because I
wanted to show mr. Michael Rapaport what
the strap looks like he's got that [ __ ]
he's got it is the 10 watts kill you
he's still one
he didn't win dude the fate of our show
and he used to be able to dunk a
basketball we can't we can't this isn't
Russia we can't allow hey how long how
long do you have to live because that's
that's not real you've got you've got
black lung but do you get black like are
you in a coal mine
what would you you guys listen you need
to stop being impartial [ __ ] listen I
want to ask you this Theo von Krista
Leah who else has been on the show that
are up for 2018 guess the year yeah Nick
Kroll Nick Swardson Thalia SAS no Lea
happy hard hope you know you know riff
again Santino yeah who's Santino I'm
just saying Santino show times I'm dying
up an actor maybe I told you these
comics they're not in my my wheelhouse
to my level do Nitin but Nick crawls
more than a comic done you know I'm
saying mm-hmm
Italy Italian he says well I'm just
saying no disrespect I'm a fan but so he
says more than a comic based on what's
on what uncle drew other people did you
see uncle drew though I liked uncle drew
I know I know you of course I liked
uncle drew but I was he in it yeah yeah
but I mean that's not why anyone went to
go see uncle no disrespect I'm a fan
we're out LA is it big mouth big nothing
never heard of the cartoon it's on
Netflix hmm I'm a grown man I don't
watch cartoons bro I'm just saying I
don't watch cartoons but like you guys
are like impartial
Fox you look Chris D'Elia you've been
juggling his [ __ ] balls yes he used
to open for myself baby but you've been
holding that dick my pup he's mad all we
do is put it we put we go hey vote who
you think is guest the year and then we
look at the votes and then we give the
belt so you don't think so you don't you
don't have any say in it zero dude we
haven't we do nothing we fat cake I
wanted you to win and I have machine
keep it funky with me chin yeah keep it
funky you're in here you're like [ __ ]
stiff don't you have to sit through all
this [ __ ]
keep it real get some [ __ ] balls and
keep it real you two cat who's the
[ __ ] guest of the year as of now
who's been your most entertaining as of
now keep it [ __ ] real chin you've
been you like this and are most
energized yeah I'm just here no you're
gonna go to the comics ordinary okay I'm
doing this and I'm gonna go to I know
this weekend no but but or no I'm
opening for so until yeah my first time
overseas doing comedy listen that's not
a good impression I'm a lot of our
comment okay but you're being super
unfair get that [ __ ] get that [ __ ]
dick hold it in your hands and make a
decision right now
you know Chin's never been hitting the
nuts before ever he's 42 to 41 41 years
old he's never been in
effort I'm not judging him that's a good
thing yeah like why you hate no onion
you've never been here in the nuts
yeah playing ball where you were a cup
when you play ball
where'd you hope now you fit yourself
with a cup yeah I got one special fitted
so what all right take it easy
chitchat whose guests of the year you
can say in front of rap you say [ __ ]
I'll say this you're gonna be really
hard to beat now you've only been here
for one of my appearances so how she's
been here for a while now okay so how
long have you been here all these you
all this year last six months not even
last six month okay but you've seen
you've seen the [ __ ] you've seen your
other other appearances okay so chill
cat listen I'm not asking you out on a
date I'm a married man
I got two kids okay I got a vasectomy
I'm not on anything from married I
really didn't keep going up you gone you
can judge it sit sit this isn't a
personal thing we're not going out on a
date you're [ __ ] staring at me like
you want to but that's not what this is
about
Wow okay who is the guest of the year so
far that you've witnessed yeah you've
seen as a fan be honest right now it's a
toss-up between you and Will Sasso
that's who's will hot Will Sasso oh let
me see a picture Jerri confuse all these
white comics with good you think this
sort of good-looking comics and comic
he's improv guy man has an improv guy
did he go to UC BC and act on that
that's Will Sasso right will and he'll
[ __ ] take your man Sasso and crush
your head come on bro no I don't I don't
like funny looking guy way bigger than
you were I don't I'm just saying I don't
like funny-looking guys well your be
what do you talk about on the show he's
it's so memorable oh he's easy genius go
to some current offense he's a genius
I'm Carly I got some kern events i
forget we're doing it what do you got I
come in here to win you did well
you've done well you've done well let me
wear that half for a minute nope is your
hair like not extra perfect underneath
there and though yeah I mean if you
really want away you can wear it so I
wanna be white you man please do these
are cats Amy Schumer joins Rihanna to
protest NFL won't appear in Super Bowl
ads here's the thing I heard she wasn't
offered a Super Bowl ad she hired a
publicist to announce
so she could get media and traction I'm
gonna tell you something here's my
problem with it if that's your stance
that's fine Amy Schumer even though no
one asks you to do it here's the thing
now you goes I think it'd be horrible or
it'd be really cool if maroon 5 didn't
do it so then you put all the pressure
on room five like whoa oh hey this is a
big deal for us yeah I'm [ __ ] turning
one against us just cuz you super he was
never got offered a commercial she was
pretty American too isn't it I mean it
brings everybody together doesn't it
yeah I gotta say I gotta say a few
things about it Amy Schumer I [ __ ] with
her that's my girl
number one I don't think like that we
haven't heard whether or not rihanna
actually got offered it or not she did
she turned it down
whoo but how do you know that where's
that in writing like do you know her age
it's bright like Brendan you know how
this business work yes she mighta leaked
it through I mean if we tracked it it
maybe if you made yourself worthy worth
something you track it
don't you [ __ ] track this [ __ ]
story see where it came from but but for
for one person to say that another
person should not collect the check is
some [ __ ] that's way and also do you
think I [ __ ] with cap I'm rock with cap
and and his whole thing I support it
listen it went the way it went down a
little south we got away from the
message okay I think it homeland now
he's making millions of dollars you
could say he's a sellout for except in
all this money for whatever different
things but like it's like like let's say
Brendan was doing a stance right and and
you know like you were like yo I'm not
with you Baba bah bah bah and then this
became the Bryan Callen podcast so on
all seriousness and then people like
you're a sellout like yo I told you I
wasn't rocking with you here I got a man
I got mouths if he's like people think
right show business isn't a business
it's business show it's also hard to get
those kids and maroon 5 like yo that
doesn't mean they're not supporting you
know or against police brutality yeah
like I like so you know you think that
all the rappers like in the middle
rappers are up and wouldn't if they got
an opportunity all of them would would
rocket Elena Elena what I'd like to ask
Amy is what is what is it that she wants
with this she said that she said by her
not doing Super Bowl ads is the way you
hurt the NFL to make them to make a
change why
is is by hurting the appetite so what
changed we're doing the NFL it's over
he's not getting pleased not playing in
the in it out no never what did I sue
you [ __ ] I don't think you're
gonna have me back hold on what is she
doing him pull out what does she want
that she wants she said two things she
said I'm not accepting ads and she also
knows I see four other white players to
support she say support what in other
words does you want at all everybody
need a little the Neal thing you've got
taken out of context yeah it's not anti
Miller did I stand for the flag right so
when the so when the national anthem is
played
I'll stand it I'm allowed to stand for
the flag and still be against police
brutality yes right I'm allowed to be
both and I think what she's doing is is
polarizing and pitting you're if you
stand then you're for the police and for
police officers who unlawfully shoot
unarmed black kids or something that's
not true and it's a false alibi heard
not doing these ads which again she
never had the official offer to do it
she goes stand up for your brothers and
sisters of color that's how you're not
doing the ads it's not really stand
that's ridiculous aying you know like
they're they talk about brothers and
sisters of color they talk about black
Asian Spanish people like they're like
they're like they're UFOs yeah like
exactly you know like they're like
they're like they're like you know this
whole thing like like this whole thing
gets white men my white men are this
white men are that and I'm like do you
know any other people others like you
you don't like your husband your little
white man kid that little spoiled prick
you see part of the white member like
this [ __ ] as guys every day not only
that if you have it so if you're a black
actor and you get a huge Superbowl
campaign should you should you say no
hell no is that what your spine you're
gonna see does that mean that you're
against your own you're ugly and and by
the way does that mean that you're that
you have to be with quote unquote black
people for everything or can you be an
individual who stands on his own and has
to look at every everything by a
case-by-case basis she said this is a
bankrupt way to go about it so so then
let me
ask us what are the headlines like the
headline forever but you know right put
herself in like she's doing this to be
in the headlines she don't need to be in
the headlines she does she don't know
she might have to say they're saying
what she did is hired a publicist to
leak this story yeah Amy Schumer Rihanna
Amy Schumer I don't think no I believe
she did happen from a tweet she's not
about that life
she don't need no headlines or any of
that [ __ ] how hard you go for her
I'm just I'm just saying do you worry if
you wouldn't buy go if you were to watch
football if you're watching the other
fight explain this so if you're watching
football does that mean I'm for police
brutality right I mean I do you think I
mean what do we turn that I'm and a lot
of players in the NFL are of people of
color right if a last time I checked
most of them so so they're they're a
huge employer of people and they pay the
millions of dollars I understand I
understand that but I'm saying coaches
assistant coaches players etc and so
they're not kneeling so and it's also is
that or sellouts also now Arkansas the
whole [ __ ] leave isn't kneeling right
there's there's like two or three
players either they got away from that
like that that kneeling it went a whole
it was the whole side trip what was the
official NFL do and if they'll said you
you you can not come out for the now he
changed it they change ways it now
there's nothing there's nothing now you
guys are doing anymore
there's one or two Slayer guy here
created your sign yeah who is adam leave
with a cap who I [ __ ] with also but it's
like yo you could do your thing I could
do my thing and we could both be against
no one [ __ ] with police brutality if
they told you in comedy stores
comedy clubs yo you can't do that [ __ ]
before the show when you're you like you
I gotta make a living man this is my job
like people think show business is in a
business
[ __ ] got got mouths to feed and
you could be knowing your next jobs
coming by the way you don't know
[ __ ] you don't know what what do
you say
they look [ __ ] oh no one else
Chen che let me see the next
[ __ ] thing in 10 so he one musk
got locked out of his Twitter account
for tweeting that he loves the enemy I
thought he was so smart
Elon mock Scott is [ __ ] if you're so
hey why would they they just thought he
got hacked so they locked him out of his
account he laying himself tiny Wolverine
chibi means small okay well so he just
between crazy [ __ ] I thought he was so
smart he wasn't talking all that jay-z
[ __ ] and they're like this isn't Elon
Musk and thought it was hacked
oh yeah just updating guys on the news
yeah so this is like a new some last
week by the way chin your news game
you're not the news host of the year now
I mean you know today's today's Thursday
dude you're like a shotgun right now
here comes another coffee what do you
guys don't cares about and I don't smart
you got a bracket Jew coffee but did you
call what else yeah I got you coffee you
know that you caught the place freezing
in here
no water no nothing go ahead cold Diet
Coke man yeah it was absolute lukewarm
you want my now I'm for your little your
little don't say little as a medium I
[ __ ] hate when people say little
we're gonna do a bit about the [ __ ]
replica Titanic next story share about
that story at all no one cares chin
that's so funny he said I when they
tried to Bob Robert DeNiro this morning
you got this [ __ ] listen Bobby D try
killing racist they sent bombs to Obama
clean right no not Trump
you're crossing the line when you send
it to [ __ ] b.o.b hey really yeah yeah
yes you your closet but who caught his I
don't know the FBI is involved I don't
know I because because they tried blown
up Bill Clinton right but they tried
doing something but guys the aussies
them not gonna would all they check it
all his mail all the time yeah they
caught him I don't know how many I don't
know Bobby went so Bob De Niro is
untouchable
you don't [ __ ] with Bob De Niro I agree
yeah I mean what can actor yeah yeah as
new stuff is tough to watch but yeah I
hear you just from what he's done in the
past see the legend no I mean before he
went bad on Trump but you don't you
don't send him a bomb and try to kill oh
[ __ ] I mean do you now it's personal
yeah um your good news person chin
you're just like this
you've ever seen the people are really
gonna love this like dead air in the
castle did you not you can't find it you
got nothing to rot on Twitter and
[ __ ] we redid the story there's
nothing were talking about hold on New
York City says a similar package there's
reporting says his restaurant Nero's
restaurant in lower Manhattan similar by
the average to the ones we saw yesterday
come on content and infected he owns a
hotel he owns every Frenchman Bob De
Niro Robert De Niro obviously has been
very very critical and I'm not saying
Jesus Christ so they're trying to bust
and blow them up and Bill Clinton's it
seemed if a bunch of people Obama I mean
there's a handful of but really her work
though like you're not gonna [ __ ]
obviously they thought something I was
gonna get through will you get be an
idiot even they attempt to do that the
one that Robert De Niro's restaurant
that's right your best bet but I wonder
who got that I don't know it's scary
it's scary [ __ ] man it's scary you ever
got a pipe bomb in your ass what see
that's Orion the next story school
cooked far for certain kangaroo major
students was it's in Australia braska
chin I covered this literally no bull
I'm gonna keep it real I covered this
last Wednesday he struggles with caravan
but why why is that um why would that be
bad to serve kangaroo me he just didn't
notify anybody and once they found out
can't why are you answering him tell him
to shut the [ __ ] up he just said why
would it be bad if k2y swati's when
kangaroo is above [ __ ] cows bro why
you're in Nebraska and you think it's
normally give kids room meat what's
wrong with some room it's like you
answering him cat listen you seem like a
nice person you got glasses on tell him
to shut the hole Don why'd you have a
problem with roommate over the ow my man
let me tell you so hey my man my man let
me tell you something I've never seen a
kangaroo in this country number one dick
get you let you go for Channel my number
two listen I eat meat I love animals
I respect animals but like like people
say oh the cows I don't think they
should be mistreated and all that [ __ ]
but surely but at the [ __ ]
right at the end of the day if we didn't
wanna do cuz they're cute cuz they're
cute and they keep their babies in
a little pouch I don't know my man I
don't I've never said why would a
kangaroo
why would kangaroo meat be served to
students in the scheme because it's not
should you don't even know who's on it I
don't you're just waiting to catch a
road movie they Rosina bro proven
they're not news people usually can
knows a [ __ ] she knows nothing
cat knows nice I could tell you think I
don't know K this guys pulling up
stories that I did on to potty nice to
go it's tough I'm not gonna blame those
stories on anyone but what else you got
you let me show you some other stories
some other stories oh you know -
Beatrice Johnson and Ben Askren are in
talks for a trade Wow
so one championship is gonna actually
probably take on Demetrius Johnson and
then Ben Askren is probably gonna go to
the UFC everyone do I don't know what do
you mean like trade what they're gonna
trade been a Sinatra fights left on his
contract with one Fc for Demetrius
Johnson soda me just didn't go over to
Japan so it would be essentially if the
ABA in the NBA existed if there was to
basketball you know I got you which it's
good because hopefully this is the first
of many because then it's not such a
monopoly on the UFC so let's say Ryan
Bader would be phaidor he's the
heavyweight champion why can't Ryan
Bader fight frickin DC if DC wins or in
DC fights the winner of the one Fc like
you just you have you the best of the
best fight each other I got you are kind
of like our boxing there's not just one
game in town I got you it'd be cool are
there are other prominent fighters in
these other ballot or I mean what what
what the PFL is doing they have some
their concepts really cool but it's
basically Bellator and UFC okay Ben
Askren you guys I don't know who he is
he's a [ __ ] what weight is he he
155 ideally 165 we can find it 170 and
and he could compete with you at the
best of UFC guys probably beat almost
everyone anyone to him I deferred to you
see he's a [ __ ] monster and you know
it's cool him and Dana hate each other
and what's cool is you know just shows
that Dana's as he gets older is you know
getting smarter about things cuz he went
alright [ __ ] my ego we'll do a trade
bring over Ben Askren he say he's the
best let's see what
made of it's pretty cool how old has
been asking now jabbing never been hit
never been hit in a fight never get hit
in a fight doesn't get hit his last I
think something like eight he's 34
Danny an Olympic wrestler I've never
been punched his style he doesn't get
punched it's just style and he's last
night his last like 12 fights he's never
been hit so so what weight is he
170 so who's the other who that other
three fighters 170 that he'd fight Nate
well would Lisa's training partner
so he's fighting I can fight Woodley so
I could if kabhi would take the fight
that's what he's 65 khabib he just got
him and Darren till going back and forth
on Twitter at 170 his Nate Diaz hasn't
fought in so long now I think it's a
goddamn shame yeah I mean it's you know
what for him it's just you know it's
more about them fighting now because
he's such a big star now there's like
five of them he's such a big star he was
gonna fight us important to Gordon in
the garden Poirier gets hurt so then
they trying to figure out late minute
replacement I think what happens next is
Union Nate Diaz Conor trilogy that'd be
the next fight from way it's team to it
I don't think Connor wants that smoke I
think he does that's a good better man
matching way better matchup than anybody
like Tony first ins a tough matchup for
him could be tough man I agree Nate Nate
Diaz at 55 I grunt 555 no five I agree I
agreed that would be good but it just
takes like that when it takes so long I
think it's not fair to the fans it's not
fair to the fighters like you gave
that's on Nate that's not the UFC's off
from tons of fights he's just letting
the taking okay it's not a Nate Diaz not
you know you see how I defer to you
because you're a UFC guy and then you
asked me about different sports or
something and then like no one's ever
gone well what do you think Brian no
because they don't once said that the
whole time but I have very deep insights
but no one no one ever goes you know I
record on Brian you're the expert on no
I'm fighting yeah I know fighting did
Fighting's my secret garden yeah be if
you don't know who Ben Askren is you
need to do some homework that's why I
asked you do what I'm telling you is a
[ __ ] but don't shame me the only bad
question when you don't anti agree oh he
also can talk [ __ ] with the best of them
he's American he's [ __ ] he's beat our
guy so bad he got in the back
ride him like a cowboy I saw that clip I
didn't know he was a [ __ ] talker I
didn't know about that one really Wow
all right he's gonna be great for the
you see anything on when his first ride
will be I bet they announced it pretty
soon okay do that next story a month ago
chain-gang story megyn kelly if he saw
her show The Today Show she said
something about blackface what'd she say
well basically it's Halloween all right
so she's like why can't people just for
Halloween one day dress up like their
favorite people well I mean why don't
you do it make it Kelly this mic see
what she said dressed up like your favor
and go black place and it like threw
Diana Ross why can't I suggest for me
I'm fired her buyout was 64 million
so listen she got fired fresh yeah megyn
kelly so this what you should do 64 milk
it a great big voice of Castille show up
to a show go short to showing show to a
Halloween party in Atlanta or like deep
Brooklyn central wherever in blackface
not as megyn kelly and see you'll figure
out why we're so sensitive about like
what was the intention behind it really
wasn't to antagonize no no [ __ ] and like
oh like my tears - [ __ ] yeah this was
an excuse to get rid of a show wasn't
doing well but when you hear the tone
she was she was throwing a net I don't
think so I'll tell you what you didn't
even hear it but I mean the intent what
she could show up is black face purple
face green face at my house
Jesus this this boat out you can tell
don't you think that there's way too
much in this like that there's just so
doing everything I do think what our
intention behind her intention has so
the whole show she her intention when
you when you see it you would know that
she was poking and I just like your wood
but does she deserve to have her show
camps for the 64 mill she's good her by
out 64 million yeah still those I am who
was her [ __ ] agent it's just it's
also if you call enough non racist
racist that I wonder I agree that it's
over the top right and and I and I get
that but the left is so sensitive that
it's like I don't know where we go from
here
I think the rights is sensitive too I
agree I think but that's what happens is
you get the far left in the far right
controlling the dialogue and
whole [ __ ] thing so the reasonable
middle stays quiet have I told you about
my voter campaign no it's um our actual
voter campaign like everyone else
it's a hashtag vote or shut the [ __ ] up
so if you don't vote November 6 yeah I
can't complain anymore no don't protest
no hashtag I think that's a good that's
a go Twitter know anything no no but
being a fox we know it takes a little
while to be an informed voter doesn't
take that long yeah but I know it takes
well I think when you're on the free
side effort it's asking the question
it's like anything but we have the far
left in the far right or at least not
the far far left and far right a little
bit strong words but you definitely have
these two very polarized tribes
controlling the whole thing and if you
say one thing despite with you I agree I
agree it's just out of control
yeah and it's all about destroying your
reputation your job you're on the get a
living it's [ __ ] up but it is it is it
is a what's the name of my voting
campaign shut the [ __ ] up some vote vote
vote or suck my dick shut the [ __ ] up
vote or lick my ass right no that's
actually I vote for that's pastor I'm
sorry campaign cuz everybody else is
what has that petition Netflix write
down no I like see this what was it dude
I'm sorry man I don't think you are I
promise I know cuz you're like you know
I see you're smiling
no you're making funny in his eyes huh
I believe his eyes I don't I don't
believe him cuz you're you're a
deceptive person no he's deceptive next
to that it's hashtag voter shutter next
next one is that right vote or shut the
[ __ ] up ya next story from September go
there make a shirt of that though
instead of your generic boxing shirt bro
yeah how many things ome sold 17 of
those god damn bro
okay guy will finish the [ __ ] hour
and a half here alright so the backup
quarterback for the Denver Broncos of
Denver Broncos
Oh cuz I'm laughing I know he was a
baller me every Broncos he did it he was
at a party von Miller's party a
Halloween party and he got super super
wasted and then it all cause like an
altercation there got kicked out he
ended up going into someone's
like a random person's house sitting
next to a woman and her child so the
husband finds out on that Robert Robert
Downey jr. yeah that means he's sucking
off [ __ ] so husband came back with a
vacuum cleaner like tube and hit him in
the back he just went outside cops got
him later and then he got fired from the
Broncos [ __ ] man he had a lot of
potential - and also that's Jim Kelly's
nephew yeah so I didn't just this good
story I didn't hear about that one yet I
feel like that's a little overkill -
right no he's got some trouble in
college yeah this is kind of his MO yeah
they gave him a shot and you show up in
someone else's braylon's house it's a
next to a woman you're drunk or whatever
we're gonna cut you and you're not
playing that right now if you're you
know if you're [ __ ] Cam Newton
they're gonna be multiples Cam Newton I
never met him yeah he's a bit your same
person yo your monster Camden giant yo
he's bodyguard sighs shut the [ __ ] up
what sport does he play football what
positions weren't like [ __ ] bastard
he was reporting on by John linka yeah
there you go due to multiple off-field
incidents and thrown off clumps of
football team by by the 2013 season an
arrest in 2014
Kelly also later played at the
interested Mississippi yeah he's a bit
of a [ __ ] up yeah you're gone he's not
his [ __ ] uncle Jim Kelly bye-bye is
that it
that's it that's all the news story sad
world we do we miss anything rap I mean
there's so many different things we
could've did for news stories we had
[ __ ] I mean it's moot about Machine
Gun Kelly and Eminem or some [ __ ] like
you do on your podcast what do you want
to talk about this one what's that mean
ah [ __ ] man can I go to her parties all
alone after one shows up this birthday
baby you're an [ __ ] picture what the
mom took the picture I'm thinking like
why would you take post yeah he's gonna
have to live this down I'm a loser [ __ ]
man poor not not poor the moms a dumb
analyst poor kid though just overall
he's probably a little prick that's why
your mom hates his father cuz he's old
white guy that's so sad to me Brian said
if you don't have any friends for your
party don't throw a big-ass party and
don't post it on Facebook then this is
some sort of scam where is this broad
from my desk
Arizona six-year-old boys party no one
showed up because your son
probably an [ __ ] to mom's probably an
[ __ ] the mom's probably the [ __ ]
they probably were like you know what we
don't want to be around the mom she's
such an [ __ ] that she's gonna watch
we won't show up and then she'll post a
picture of her son to try to get money
for him online she's an [ __ ] good
story [ __ ] won't do one more chin wait
here's the update to a story the Phoenix
Suns invited him to the this is a scam
what is it's not don't look at that poor
little no this was like this was a scam
there was the best save his life because
right and he showed up to the game well
you'll see the mom oh you guys aren't
watching that [ __ ] uh the making of
murder he got a girlfriend pretty hot
girlfriend this [ __ ] scumbag while he
was in jail and yeah he was he engaged
with her and then she started doing she
did dr. Phil she got all famous and I
just made some money and just dipped out
on him she'll I'm God I could be honest
[ __ ] oh I'm glad that I'm not in these
times a young single dude because you
you you you know they to quote a BB D I
know he doesn't know never trust a big
butt in a smile God breach right yup
reach that's all BBD never just a big
butt and smart let me redeem himself rap
he's usually good airplane crashed on
the 101 they're not seen on a plane
you'll imagine if you're on the 101 this
is also from last week yes I already
covered this last week for another one I
want a Nazi plane crash I think it's
World War three yo I would be like [ __ ]
an old Nazi plane on the 101 I'm
thinking terrorism for sure
Brian's lost all energy in his body you
know instead of wording 7-minute good is
that this one your age catches up with
you right now me and rapper here's a
large maybe this that's where I'm Jo god
damn I joke I'd be scared as [ __ ] for
number one it's a plane crash on the 101
number two it's a Nazi plane [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
well hell no [ __ ] Amy Amy no no it's
fine you're you're dragging do with
energy say who's anybody to hurt sit
damn buddy you
stop the show Brian's last all right I'm
fine guys all right when does your show
premiere which one the Goldberg which
one I'm on a lot of difference no no
[ __ ] hashtag talented I don't know
yeah I'm not sure but be ready cuz
you'll hear a loud noise called success
Thank You e typicals out season 3 season
2 is out but season 3 7 no season 3 is
happening she said congratulations mine
can grab why I told that before no you
did yes Congrats on a tip with season 3
the big three [ __ ] me I'll be at The
Improv Comedy Store Monday almost shut
[ __ ] down I'll be there heckling the
[ __ ] please do my thighs they look like
circus of mice that's a bad
oh my thighs they look like circus Moe
maybe there was something I said a long
time ago about you say it every [ __ ]
bit are those dwarves wrestling in your
jeans or something I heard somebody say
look at my thighs like this felt am i
right what would give dudu bright counts
Jack I can't no I can't bro me and Brian
are on the road together named Cisco you
know the whole whacked like when he's
doing his acting all right do you like
you were to watch you on Monday I'm
coming in you're the best dude I'll give
you notes yeah I'm the best meaning I'm
the guest of the year no we'll see well
that's a fancy side but you're up there
you're up there you've been a
disappointed sigh can VP of the NBA
there's few good ones well you're up
there what the fans vote
look it Mike smiling man hey Mike I want
you to apologize you were a little rough
with me this this and I didn't know you
were gonna be here I gotta be honest I
didn't want you sir it's me as somebody
who knows sports and I know some
something about sports no you don't you
you landed here I'm sorry I finished
this is the viral kid with rap we're
alpha